私はアートが好きで
アートの村を作りたくて
今アートの村を作っています去年からの
コロナの時
自分の人生どこへ向かって歩いていけば
いいのか
何をしたいのか分からず時間だけが過ぎて
いってました
このとき私の人生は根本とゾーンの中に
入ってしまっていました
このままじゃいけない
この高本とゾーンを抜け出すために人生で
大きな一方
いたしました
ビーダーある thisああ頼むらー
花は季節によってたくさんの花を咲かせ
ます
ここはアーティストが花を咲かせるように
作品を咲かせるところ
みんなが持つ
アートの心をオープンにできるところ
そして自分が持っているアートの心を持っ
ていると気づくところ
私が選んだのは8の女と書いてヤメ
という山と川に囲まれた街
築八十余年の古民家とには全体を使って
いまアートな村を作っています
去年5月まで福岡市のレストランで7年間
働いていました
レストランの前は高校生に書道を教えてい
ました
この学校では
出会える人は生徒と学校の先生
しかしレストランではその場合の場合の
場合のたくさんのいろんな人に出会える
ことができました
またアーティストやーアートたくさん
触れることができて
私はアートが
もっともっと好きになりました私の書道の
良いスピレーションの源はアートです
私の普通で内緒の表現
紙だけではなくビニールに書いたり
人の顔に書いたり
手で書いたり炭だけではなくいろんな色を
使って
書を表現しています
日本だけではなくイタリアや台湾
北アイルランドたくさんのところに行って
書を表現していきました
そこで変わったシチュエーションでショー
を書いていきます
佐賀県の嬉野温泉和多屋別荘という旅館の
パフォーマンスです
これは嬉野川に4つのパネルを浮かばせ
私も彼はに入り
パフォーマンスをしていました
流れる水を書にして表現しています
そして北九州のファッション百万夏まつり
のオープニングのパフォーマンスです
だしはこの6メートルと言うかいたことも
ない大きさに5分で書を書いていきます
この時処理を通して日本舞踊を習っていた
私は諸島日本舞踊を織り交ぜた
パフォーマンスをしています
ni
rar
as
aniああああああ
ni
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
ani
ウォッシャブルん
[音楽]
ni
[拍手]
うわ寸
[音楽]
心
ni
whああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
goo
me
[音楽]
ana
北九州市は5つの街からなっている子です
そして北九州市のシンボルのひまわりを5
つ書いていますそして北九州市の地形です
事件を書いています
そして熊本県のあんま天草望洋閣という
旅館のパフォーマンスです
ここは日本夕陽百選に選ばれた場所です
このいう人小大コラボレーションしたい
透明のアクリル板に文字を書き
いこ一刻一刻と背景が変わっていくその
パフォーマンスです
私にとって
昭和
自分の言葉
自分の気持ちを表現する一番のツールです
そして私は日本語がへたくそです
皆さんも気づいていると思います
私はこのレストランでアートと出会って
このその表現が変わりました
そして人生も
変わりました
働いていたレストランではあなたの
イベントをしていました
art de ナイトというイベントです
これはアーティストとアートが好きな人
みんな一緒にアートの心をオープンにして
楽しむ時間
エアー
写真や音楽
たくさんのアーティストが自分の作品を
持ってきてみんなでアートをシェアします
その中の一つで映画のイベントがありまし
た
まちや紳士録という
ドキュメンタリー映画の上映会です
この映画の舞台は
過疎化が進む
止めの城下町
江戸時代から残る街やが止めにはあります
その江戸時代の建物の保存と
継承をする大工さん
そして止めの人たちの姿
三重県から移住して止めに移住してきた
ばかりの伊東監督がカメラを回し
自分の生活も織り交ぜた映画です
この止めの大工さんや止めの人達を
みてください
[音楽]
僕のチアの正小学校空港ですよね
空き家とかはなかったですよね
[音楽]
新人じゃ
0円
ええええええ
ん
[音楽]
jr
meん
me
ni
wh
日本文化と古いものが私はイベントが
終わった後
すぐに止めに行ってきました
そこにはこの映画に出ていた町家や
人たちがそこにはいました
映画の中で一番私が見たかった場所
映画の中では
5止めでは一番大きく建物で一番古い
ポロポロで近所の目近所の人からは迷惑
がられていたこの建物
130年前の旧八女郡役所です
実際私はそこに行ってきました
そしたら全く違う
こんなに綺麗になっています
映画の中ではブルーシートが屋根にかけ
られて窓ガラスが割れ
中は誰も住んでいなかったので廃材だらけ
です
しかし
瓦や壁窓ガラスは一例になり中には酒屋
さんも入ったり壁もある人の姿があるん
です
そして中に入ってみると
子は130年前の姿が残っているようでし
た
力強い柱は
命が吹き返したように立っていて
たくさんの人が歩いたと思う
でここだけどすごく歩きやすい
天井を見れば
大きな針
タイムスリップできるような感覚でした
各いいと思ってこの場所で絶対消防の個展
をしたい
すぐに思って
これここからやめとこの旧八女郡役所に
毎月かへ通うようになります
そして半年後
ここで初動画個展役を開催しました
この柱をなるべく
見せるような展示方法
和紙を使って
天井からつり下げました
もちろんつり下げたのは私です
高さ
だいたい7メートルぐらいの高さがあり
はしごは木の梯子です
片方だけですっ
それを登って屋根9天井から吊るし
また土間も皆には見てほしかったなので
年度で文字を作り床に黒展示会
私の書よりもこの分野助の
あっあっとされる存在感
が感じるパフォーマー展示会でした
この個展をきっかけにバイオリンやギター
のアーティストおよび一緒に来比較した
コンサート
ここで所のパフォーマンスも実現しました
古典や止めに通うようになり
たくさんの試合が増えていきます
一つ第2
人を紹介してもらってそこに行って話を
するその繰り返しです
誰も知らなかった八女の町
どんどん
知り合いが増えていきます
止めに住みたい
このとき私はレストランで働き
所の活動をし福岡市のマンションに住む
しかし目的これからの目的が
わからず
自分を抑えたり
自分に嘘をついたり
自分ができてない
人に嫉妬したりしている状態でした
しかし
この止めでたくさんのいろんな人に出会い
自分が居心地がいい場所を見つけ
この7年間働いたレストラン
やめて
止めで古民家を見つけ一人で移り住みまし
た
ここです
築八十余年の古民家
7 sdk
済んだことも聞いたこともない広さです
中にはは90平米もあります
そして別の建物で走行
そして車庫もついています
私がこのヘで一目惚れしたのは玄関から
見るこのエンドランプです
実は中を見ずに申し込みました
プランだけで決めました
しかしこの時33歳の女性1人で家を買う
こと
沢山の銀行に書類を出すけどローンが通ら
ない
私にとってとっても価値がある立派
この古民家が一般的には価値がないと判断
される
不動産屋さんに
期限ギリギリまで待ってもらえ2番手3番
手の人もいたのでギリギリまで待って
もらいどうにかこの家を手に入れました
やっと止めの家を手に入れ引越した当日の
夜
都会の夜中3時まで明るいクラスになれて
いた私は
c
という文字が聞こえるくらい
静かで真っ暗な街でした
そしてこの広い敷地に一人きりです
玄関やキッチン色んなところでん気を
つけるけど結局寝れませんでした
そして冬になると水道管の破裂
初めての車のエンストーン
そしてこの一軒家を一人で掃除したりこの
中には
草6 c です
アートの心もっと出したいと思って
引っ越ししてきたのに自分の家の
メンテナンスねああ
全くその時間もなく一人落ち込む時もよく
ありました
しかし福岡の友達が草むしりに行くよー
来てくれたり
家具を一緒に運んでくれる友達
おかげで私の家一つ一つの家具にはみんな
の血が入っています
そしてこの家の中にたくさんのアートを
作りたい
自分でふすまを破って
和紙を貼ったり自分の作品を張ったり
窓ガラスに
作品も春
いろんな
色を練る
窓ガラスや
どこかん
はい無断でペインティングしてしまうと
行えるようなところですがここは自由に
行ってきます
くすまにを書きました
ランプ制度も作ったり
畑からスズキをとってカーテンにしました
ん
木の枝もオブジェになるんです
こうやってどんどん
たくさん自分のアートの心を解放していき
ました
そして毎月
ヨナのイベントを
して止めの人や効果の人が集まる
コミュニティの場所づくりをしました
そして書道を通して新しい自分を発見
できるワークショップ
実はみんな目をつぶって書いた作品です
そして
石の臼で打つ餅つき大会や
薪窯で焼く kids party
夜のフリーマーケットや
ライブですね
そして夜のギャラリー
大きなエントランスのところにいろんな
アートおいてギャラリーの展示もしました
こうやって一人で来たところが
たくさんの人が来てくれて私が
目指すアートの村にどんどん近づいていき
ます
アート村日だアルティス
広場です
もともとここは畑だった場所です
草むしりに悪戦苦闘したところです
そこがきれいになり今では広場になってい
ます
私は日本の古民家や田舎が大好きです
しかしみんなが集まる広場がないんです
ここは誰でも来ることができる
一人で来ても誰かがいる
最悪私いますふーん
ここに今
キレイになっていますがもっと綺麗な広場
にしていきたい
自分が
デザインしてカラフルなモザイクタイルを
置いたり
木の柱を立てて q 8
バラの花ふじの花葡萄の緑の屋根を作り
たい
そしてアートです
彫刻やギャラリーいろんなところを見ても
アートがたくさんある広場にしたい
そして
沢山の
人がいます
音楽をしている人学校帰りの子どもたちの
集合場所
何よりアートが好きな人や
人が好きな人
伝統工芸の職人さんみんなが集まって
次の世代の子に種をまく
種をまくように伝えていくこと
その他ね彼らはアイディアや
アートやコミュニティという花を咲かす
ことができます
私は足踏みをして
この先どこへ向かっていいのかわからない
状態から一人で止めに行くことを選びまし
た
踏み出しました
見えない先の不安より
見える一方踏み出すそうすると必ずもう
一歩だして歩かなければなりません
みんなが前を向いて歩く世界はこんなにも
花がいっぱい
人がいっぱいに溢れる場所が世界中にどこ
でも見ることができると思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]